get this one out of Los Angeles right
now we've got a quote from Fox La here
this is wild a protest how held outside
of Glendale this is Los Angeles a
Glendale school board meeting over the
students right to choose their pronouns
took a chaotic turn Tuesday evening
multiple groups gathered outside the
Glendale Unified School Board building
as they protested over pronouns at one
point during the protests punches were
thrown and police in Glendale had to
jump in to stop the violence meanwhile
in Los Angeles LAUSD board Annette
unanimously approved a resolution
Tuesday encouraging all schools to
incorporate lgbtq Plus Class Concepts as
part of the curriculum in addition to
formerly recognizing June AS lgbtq Plus
pride month while also designating
October as lgbtq History Month Jesus the
commotion and fights faded shortly after
the fight as crowds were ordered to
disperse in Temecula so this is a little
bit outside of Los Angeles teachers
gathered to protest Temecula Valley
Unified School District board's decision
to exclude certain textbooks from the
curriculum the controversy in Temecula
surrounds the debate over social social
studies textbook proposed for the fourth
grade curriculum okay we're going to
show you some video in just a second of
what happened in Glendale where a bunch
of parents were basically saying uh no
we are not going to push this woke crazy
gender stuff and pronoun nonsense on our
children and they've had it with this
craziness but La so now there's two gay
months they took June and now and now
they want October too and they're making
sure that this stuff is taught in school
I have said this many times I don't have
a problem with gay people my husband is
gay all right it's not an issue but you
shouldn't why would you be teaching this
in schools how about teaching math and
history
etc etc anyway here is uh some of the
video
from the fight that broke out these are
radical trans activists with antifa
people and far left protesters duking it
out with these are mostly Armenian
Glendale is like home of the Armenian
community in Los Angeles these are
mostly Armenian American uh parents in
Glendale take a look
yeah
oh my God
guess what guys this is going to happen
more and more across blue cities and
blue States because for the slim set of
people that will live in these places
that are still sane I mean think about
it do you think that it doesn't matter
that these parents are Armenian or
anything else they that happens to be
very Armenian Community actually I can't
say it has nothing it doesn't matter at
all like the Armenian people seem like
they care about reality at least in this
community and that's pretty good right
the more do you think that any of those
parents were waking up every day like
let's get out there and protest gays
guess what there are gays that live in
Glendale nobody cares nobody cares if
you keep pushing this nonsense through
the curriculum at the schools on their
children eventually parents say enough
is enough as you know this is what
caused Glenn Younkin to win in Virginia
he started backing the parents instead
of the radicals right
um so it's not as if so I don't know who
started the fight I don't know who threw
the first Punch or maybe spit on
somebody or anything else but you must
understand there's a set of people who
are radical activists who are trying to
indoctrinate others people's children
and then there's a set of parents whose
ultimate responsibility is to take care
of their children so it is fairly
obvious who the good guys are
[Music]
thank you